need motivation watch a top 10 with the
lead nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you as well you have Michael Jordan
level talent at something so get ready
to focus on serving don't have regrets
and master one thing with Gary
Vaynerchuk and my take on his top ten
rules to success to give you the
confidence motivation and belief that
you need enjoy okay let's kick it off
with rule number one focus on serving I
don't have any super arsenal of apps you
know like I use all the same everybody
else does I just it's what I fill the
platforms width is what matters
everybody's got the same everybody
starts with zero followers and
everybody's got the same apps that
everybody's on it's what you fill it
with the biggest difference between me
and the far majority of the market is
every time I put out a piece of content
I literally through my brain in my soul
think what's this gonna do for them
ninety nine percent of people when they
post think about what's this
that's how many like how many likes am I
gonna get how many t-shirts am I gonna
sell who's gonna see this that's gonna
feel cool for me everything's about me
me me me me which is why everything
seems the same which is like everything
sitting in a swan in a pool in the
Hamptons it's like it's all the same
flowers in the erica chela gold faking
watches jumping fences to take a photo
at the private plane place it's all the
same to me me me the second you don't
think that way the second everything
changes and growing up in restaurants
and retail stores where you serve is an
incredible framework and I got lucky
that I went through those experiences
before this world came because it became
my framework rule number 2 live in the
trenches one of the great reasons my
company does well is there's not a
single person that works at vaynermedia
that does the work more than I do as the
CEO of my company there's not one
employee that works for me that produces
more content deploys more ads like I'm
living in the trenches I'm a
practitioner I'm in meetings sometimes
with the platforms were I'm correcting
their mistake of what their platform can
do rule number three have empathy so
what's the secret of making people
engage with your content I mean it's
it's gem sports empathy okay
empathy is the secret I believe I sit at
where I am in lexicon which is I think a
winning player in today's new
environment because I'm empathetic to my
audience I put out content that brings
them value not makes me feel good about
myself
rule number four be patient oh the poor
things like pushing
because I believe in it the most is
patience
so many people could be successful the
problem is they're trying to get there
so fast they're cheap and any lose
they're not super complicated it's
really not it's like everybody's so like
passionate of looking successful that if
them up from actually being successful
I'm kind of fantasizing of like moving
to another country starting from the
beginning just because the beginning is
my favorite part it's the process it's
the process and that's the fantasy
that's the same point of like it's easy
for me to be patient because I like
playing more than I like the things that
playing gives me and everybody wants to
stuff it playing gives them also if you
want to have more confidence and self
love check out my 250 for series they're
free the link to join are in the
description below
we are sluggish we're really strong
we're just being sold that we're not
because there's a lot of money my
ability to only be comfortable in
massive chaos has been my biggest asset
as an entrepreneur like I would never
take a note like that scares the piss
out of me what these three people are
doing right now in a success world
please understand that success is
happiness not net dollars in rule number
five don't have regrets when people like
what have you done wrong and I'm always
like like I haven't really I haven't I
don't I'm too much of an immigrant and
always have a nest egg and never put
myself in a position to lose it all
because I don't care enough about the
mutlaq so I'm never gonna be like that
guy but the things I've done wrong are
the things I haven't done the things
I've done wrong they're the things I
have not done
missed opportunities that are hidden
that I'll never know if what the I don't
know what have I done wrong I should
have done that TV show I should have
gone that yacht with that billionaire I
should have like a million things I've
done wrong I mean I should have said yes
to Bert why I mean the Delfin my uber is
five hundred million dollars that's a
lot of money on the only person I
thanked in my book besides my family
like it's not like some random guy
pitched me a my homey
because I bought a house that I wasn't
super liquid and there was a side
project so all my biggest mistakes sort
of things I haven't done not the things
I've done rule number six be good you
know what's going on in Silicon Valley
when Steve Jobs when his height young
dudes thought they had to be like Steve
do you know how excited the Claude can
tell you better do you know what we're
doing here I'm inspiring a totally
different Alf executive female and male
that's huge that's legacy that's cool
like what like you could be an alpha
assassin winner and have a heart as your
logo what then you know it may seem to
you might be too close to it but it's
super cool it's super different and it's
go see I listen to markets more than you
I love you guys see ya
that's why I love you know listen mister
you know actions over words I'm very
much a good guy and wanted to like do a
lot of nice things and I'm also want to
buy the New York Jets like you can have
you can be you know and I think that's
where people are getting caught they
feel like you either have to be an alpha
businessman and kill everybody ruthless
and terrible or you need to be a hippie
and I'm like why can't you be both
why can't you succeed by being good and
being a good person and being a good
operator and successful it's kind of
like how I think about athletes athletes
are allowed to be really tough on the
field trip for you and bragging that you
know and then when the game's over
because your families shared jerseys for
business people that's how I think about
it when I'm making business decisions
I've got a you know I've got a win rule
number seven find strength in adversity
we have the highest rate of suicide
amongst kids I'm talking eighteen year
olds and younger like my two cousins is
that a is that a poverty issue is that a
issues of self-esteem issue because they
see to me it's like they see things on
social media and their life doesn't beer
that cuz it's still dirt floors walking
outside to use the bath
but but to your point like the the thing
that really matters is like look no
television didn't give them images
either right like like the current state
is your Instagram feed
it used to be MTV Cribs it's all the
same it's either you're good with what
you've got or you're not it's either
that you're you've got FOMO of what
somebody else has or not you know which
is why it needs to become an insular
game this is you know I apologize but
they've got me the the thing they you
know the thing that you said to me and
which means that we both understand is
our humble beginnings is our strength
yes we have to my big thing with the
internet is like so when I came up I'm
43 when I came up the business world
because I was such a student and I
didn't come from the right pedigree and
I didn't go to Harvard or any go to
McKinsey I was considered to have no
chance of success like flat-out like
that was just the rules of the game
these kids the kids and dirt floors
right now in South Dakota on an Indian
Reservation the Internet allows them to
actually have a chance and so my big
thing is I now believe that to have nots
yeah I actually have a bigger advantage
because they think the haves are
entitled and soft and actually more
macro insecure like the kid the kid
who's got the best passes to Coachella
and a BMW and their parents bought their
way into a great college they're hurting
inside more than people realize because
they actually means no matter what no
matter what they achieve they didn't
achieve it their parents put them on us
though we suck and we studio apartment
six family members third floor but if we
achieve it's us
and and with this rule number eight
master one thing oftentimes I reference
Mariano Rivera when I talk about my
career no mo was one of the great
closers in baseball history and at the
end of is that and so you gotta
appreciate this he had one pitch he was
solid at everything else but he had this
one pitch and besides Edgar Martinez
literally nobody could hit it and that's
why I think I am I'm good at other
things I'm a good CEO Oh like I can
operate that's why I have businesses I'm
very good at HR I'm good at PR like I'm
good at other things but I am from this
is now me talking about myself but I if
you ask me I think I'm remarkable at
understanding what humans are actually
doing before the masses understand
they're doing it right
I understood that online dating in 2001
was gonna be mainstream that wasn't
obvious until 2011 right or 13 or
whenever tinder really took hold right
and so what I mean by that is I built
wine library on the back of email and
Google AdWords in 1997 no liquor store
in America thought it was a good idea to
build up an email newsletter versus the
catalog that they could send in the mail
got it right
in 2001 I bought every google adword for
every wine term and nobody was bidding
me up rule number nine be a marathon
runner I'm incapable of being a CEO of a
publicly-traded company so no we will
not
yeah you may be Eli must shoot six you
know I don't know what you on well
enough and I know he's a character I'm
not I'm not incapable because I want to
curse on video I'm incapable because I
don't know how to run a business that
needs to perform financially every 90
days because I'm a marathon runner not a
sprinter I don't want the cash infusion
to buy a boat I want to enjoy running a
company and I need independence as a
entrepreneur and so I'm not willing to
give up my independence for 400 million
dollars upfront and rule number 10 the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is add value I'm just starting I
have my
I'm just having trouble like producing
new content all the time
I would doc I would I would highly
recommend documenting versus creating
okay when you get into ruts just do a
day-in-the-life
or just something but like when I do
vlog type of content yeah my channel my
views are going a lot more down because
then what then like if I'm doing stuff
on because I have an audience of
programmers yes so when I'm doing stuff
with coding content or something
those get a little bit more views but
but you're pandering to views instead of
putting out content that's true if
you're not inspired to do coding content
you're not gonna put out anything that
day I'd rather you film yourself
drinking a cup of coffee and maybe
talking about the story why you started
coding in the first place that's true
yeah because you know what the problem
big problem I'm having is that I'm kind
of I don't feel like really coding that
much anymore because I'm focusing on
running the business yeah talk about
that I'm not really related to the
people in audience when I first started
doing business videos instead of wine
videos my my views collapsed because my
audience was wine people yeah but then I
just build it back up
[Music]
you can't live your life predicated on
how many views the video is gonna get on
YouTube right so I'm just trying to okay
so yeah that's that's important for me
to understand it's the biggest important
thing for content producers to
understand everybody's getting caught up
in likes and subscribers right instead
of actually living the life
well okay so here's the thing I also
have
you know in my mind I'm running a
business as well so I'm trying to get
the so it's not just likes and
subscribers I'm trying to cultivate a
community of developers or then also
purchasing our products well then bring
them then you got to bring that value
right then every single thing that you
should be putting out has nothing to
with likes or subscribers it should be
like what in the world is gonna help
this developer and you have to make that
content with the expectation of them
never buying your product right then
you'll grow yeah that's true I know you
know many people I've changed their
lives and made them millions of dollars
and still haven't bought a sneaker of
bottled wine for me and it doesn't
bother me one bit now I have a special
bonus tip from Gary on how to invest in
your comfort zone that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that is time for
the three point landing questions let's
go from just watching the video to
taking action here we go question number
one where do you need to add more value
number two what's the one thing that you
need to master and number three who do
you need to have more empathy for and if
you liked this video and will take
action after watching it give me a hash
tag believe down in the comments below
I'm not investing a whole lot right now
I think things are overpriced
and I'm also very focused on Vayner and
green straight like the things I own
right now yeah you know like it's it's
weird what like I'm excited about like
even like the whole sports card thing
like I just know for a fact that sports
cards are about to go up quite a bit in
value and so like when somebody asked me
like what do I do with my money like I
know exactly how to make twenty five
thousand into a hundred thousand buying
giannis you know like Greek freak rookie
cards I can't say that about a million
other things so it's crazy that those
things are coming out of my mouth but
it's cuz I don't want to be vulnerable I
don't want you to send me an email and
be like dude you've told me you know
it's so like I think I think that um I
think you got to go where you're
comfortable Evan thank you so much for
having a couple seconds and being able
to tell the belief nation a little bit
about empathy wines it means a lot to me
that you would take this valuable real
estate and and
time on your channel to give me some
love means a lot it's just good karma
points and so you're just you're awesome
thank you believe nation if you're into
wine at all go to empathy wines calm my
whole careers work was poured into
producing a wine that rivaled forty to
sixty dollar wine for twenty bucks a
bottle
I'm just super excited about this
subscription-based wine business
you can order three six or twelve
bottles in subscription form Rose a
white red if you could if you searched
on Instagram or Twitter you will be
blown away people are literally like I
don't even like Gary Vee but the lines
good super proud of the effort thanks
Evan for the time wishing you guys all
happy and healthy
if you want more Gary check out the top
50 rules video I made on him the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there I don't think there's
anything wrong with chasing money I just
think that it's usually the quickest way
not to get it work ethic is controllable